Paul Theru author of Dark Star safari in
the middle of your book you have this
sentence I do not want to be young again
yeah well today's my birthday and it so
happens that I went to Africa at a
different period forty years ago and I
felt that I was entering a world that I
had very very little knowledge of and I
was stumbling through it I was not
prepared for it though I was game and
when I think of and if that was 40 years
ago I when I think of what's happened in
the intervening time I don't know
whether I'd want to go through all of
that again if I read correctly this is
the 32nd book you've written least the
ones listed in the front of this book
yes it's a I lose count but it does some
some along and some summer short those
books represent to a large extent places
that I've been places that I've thought
about a lot of fiction writing is pure
fantasy it's it's it's what if it's
giving yourself the second chance that
life denies you and I think I when I
wrote the Mosquito Coast in the 70s a
late 70s and finished at an 81 I thought
I'd always like to take my family to
Honduras but I didn't my family was in
London intent instead of taking them to
Honduras I wrote about it I and so it's
a little family it was me and my my
little family my children were those
ages so it's it's it's having that and
and working through the problem of the
fictional problem of what would it have
been like had I done that confronting
that all the complexities of that I
think early in the book we find out from
your dedication that your mother was 92
when you wrote this book is she still
like my mother read this book yeah she
read it just the other day when it came
out and liked it very much she she lives
alone she cooks for herself and is very
self-sufficient very strong woman and
and a great reader she made me a reader
so did my father so I mean she is a
literary person
account of the country's or with with
darkstar Safari people have said to how
many miles did you go and I really have
no idea because I know it no no trip is
a straight line I think that n.n in this
trip I was going from Cairo to cape town
but there are plenty of detours I might
ask you about some people I just pick
out one Susanna this is a woman I met
changed her name it wasn't Suzanne I was
thinking uh I spared her the they heard
the name I've been in many cases I
changed people's dangerous to the not
subjected to ridicule but so then I met
on a train in Mozambique she was an
evangelist she believed that all
Africans were that were not praying were
sinners and they could be saved by grace
she was also doing a little bit of
social work but mainly mainly it was the
Bible in Africa is a place where you
meet people like this who there's a bit
of myth Oh mania in it I suppose I'm
mytho maniac myself and going to Africa
Tarzan Ernest Hemingway mr. Kurtz Joseph
Conrad you know you name it people who
are doing good teachers Peace Corps all
of them see themselves in Africa as a
theater and Susannah was um just looked
upon she should look out the window all
sinners they're all sinners I said Evan
they got enough problems you did on
occasion take on missionaries yes what
do you think of them you know they come
in all shapes and sizes but for some
it's it's purely the desire to convert
and get them saved are you saved now
Africans have been through in that in
the case of this missionary in
Mozambique Mozambique has endured 25
years of civil war and 450 years of
colonia of portuguese colonialism theft
rape pillage floods recent floods
famines recent famines and and a lot of
social disorder do they really need to
be told also that having endured all
this that there
sinners i don't think so i don't think
so i think it's just the idea of
imposing religion on people who have all
of their own problems i'd say no that's
not how long were you in Africa or this
trip this trip took about five and a
half months and I set off from Cairo in
January came back in late May of a of
2001 and then later went back after nine
eleven I wanted to see various places
and see what had changed see the
attitudes of people I was in a lot of
Muslim parts of Africa and I wanted to
see how are energized how politicized
how angry they were and how they how
would they they would respond to me what
did you find I found that I found that
they they responded to me as a person
not as an emissary of an foreign enemy
hostile government but they're still
angry about I mean people in the sudan
and egypt tend to say don't forget
Palestinians Arabs generally who've been
persecuted have children and
grandchildren and they'll hate you
they'll hate your government didn't say
he'd me but hey Tamara they will hate
America that's what they said so they
think they I Americans tend to
underestimate how strongly weak people
or press people identify with the
Palestinians the Palestinians are the
martyrs for the call for the cause and I
have been very badly treated we can see
that you know all the time and I I think
we underestimate how they're that were
this symbolic value of Palestine you
said in your book this is the last time
you're going to do one of these road
trips things where you've got you know
you're running around in trucks and all
the the ways you did it in Africa why
and then tell us how many different ways
you traveled from Cairo to Cape Town the
never again was the bush taxi with 20
people crammed into a minivan
or an old bus a standing headline in
American newspapers is many killed in
bus plunge Hara in Kenya many killed in
Kenya bust plunge hora I understanding
had I thought a travel writer killed in
bus plunge hora it just as too many
people the roads are bad that the
drivers are they go too fast they're
inexperienced so it's I didn't want to
subject myself to that also if you end
up in an African hospital you never come
out the modes of transport I went down
the nile by train and boat I went
through the Sudan by train and tak
attack bush taxi and a rented land rover
with a guy because I wanted to go on a
camping trip in the Sudan I took a train
in Ethiopia bus hitched a cattle truck
the only way you can get from the
Ethiopian border to SEO low in northern
Kenya the most dangerous part of my trip
I was shot at was cattle truck that
sounds like bad news it but if you're in
a cattle truck you're going to arrive
because cattle have to get to market if
you're in a truck with 20 people you may
not make it twenty cows you'll
definitely make it down the road more
bosses more trains the old German train
in Tanzania ferry across lake victoria
you know little bush taxis to malawi got
stuck in the mud as you go south in
Africa once you pass the equator roughly
speaking traveler gets slightly easier
and I went by canoe down the sherry and
the Zambezi River then buses trains
wonderful trains in south africa i went
from johannesburg took cape town on a
train and liked it so much i went back
and forth several times i didn't write
about in the book i was just sitting
there reading looking out the window
thinking this is fun did you total up
how much it cost you to do that whole
trip no I brought two thousand dollars
with me and I still had money at the end
which was stolen every five and eight
months yeah yeah and with credit cards I
bought tickets with credit cards
air tickets but i only had an air ticket
there and the most expensive thing was
in in the Sudan i had to pay cash for
everything no no credit cards there in a
in Kenya thinking things would were
cheap and I'm paid with a credit card at
some hotels you know I was thinking
hotels it costs ten dollars in what you
nee Theo p I remember the man said he
said do you want the two-dollar room or
the four dollar room I said I'll take
the four no did you travel with anyone
no no I was alone the whole time the way
I travel would be so wearing 444
traveling companion that they if it was
my wife she'd leave me or I'd leave her
I'd say because you get your place if
you're with your spouse they said well
let's go to the hotel and freshen up or
where's the hotel or they say things
like where are we going or what do you
think are we going to be okay you know
it's four o'clock in the afternoon and
you're heading for a place and you don't
know where there's a place to stay well
if you're alone you can stand under a
tree or just you know say can you take
me in whatever it is you don't know
what's going to happen traveling with
someone they're constantly asking
questions to which you don't have the
answer and then there's the writing part
if you travel alone the whole day is
yours too right to make notes and write
and i spend i spent five and a half
months in very intense either a
difficult travel and comfortable travel
or else writing about it in you know
making notes and then in the evening
spending two or three hours just copying
everything out i come back with a lot of
notes a person traveling with me
wouldn't like it what do you take with
you i take i have one of these scholar
patagonia mlc maximum legal carry on you
can take it on any plane and a little
beat-up briefcase so change of clothes a
shortwave radio no electronics no tape
recorder no computer no phone no page or
nothing like that cheap watch and that's
about it and then when i see i didn't
have any a high level meetings
mine's not a fact-finding mission or red
carpet or you know nothing nothing
official I'm the connoisseur of the low
level meeting and so although I saw
ambassadors I had a safari jacket I
would just put on my best shirt and
Safari Jack I didn't have a tie and try
to look by most decent but most the time
if I needed clothes I went to the market
and you may have given close at one time
another two clothing for Africa fund if
so I was wearing them because you get
them in law other words I had t-shirts
saying top notch plumbing and you know
Saskatchewan blue bombers and things
like that I I tried its protective
coloration I tried not to stand out this
book has no index it has no photographs
it has no source nodes is that on
purpose I've never put an index in it in
a travel book that I've written or any
book that I've written although i must
say i love indexes I love them and I
love them out the most detailed ones and
when I'm reading it a history or a
biography if the index is bad they
usually have them but sometimes the very
poor deliberately no index doesn't need
one sources you can see i if i quote a
book i quote the author and the title of
the book and anyone can find them with
the internet you just put in the name
you look go to a website use book
website put in the name the title you've
got the book sometimes people have said
to me why do you have no acknowledgments
well I it would be to be too much no one
wants to read acknowledgments and it's
it's kind of self-serving you know I'll
never forget Jane on the train or
whatever it is or this rental car
company whatever you know they always
look to me like that they've been it is
a formal patronage you know so I haven't
done that and the pictures I'd like to
think that with a book like this that
you don't need pictures or that the
pictures would would not measure up to
the provide purple prose or whatever how
many foreign languages do you speak and
how many languages did you have to speak
on this trip
I can speak Italian pretty well I
studied in school and I worked initially
so yo Paolo italiano me when I drew a
key Swahili it's not bad it's more in
the range of kitchen Swahili but I do
Chi che woo is a language that I thought
it was called shinyanga at the time they
changed the name and because they think
they claim that it was the president's
tribe chichewa is a wonderful language
and I can speak that fluently I probably
I could speak it to some taxi drivers in
Washington in the Western Hemisphere
it's not widely spoken but anywhere in
Malawi and Zambia and Zimbabwe and parts
of South Africa Chi che woo and
Mozambique Chihuahua is related to a lot
of local languages I can understand
French I can mumble my way through
Spanish that's about it really how many
actual miles is it from Cairo to Cape
Town you know I have no idea because of
the because the the kind of detours I
took I don't know you'd have to measure
with a ruler but I tried not to think
about the miles sometimes in Africa to
psych myself up for this trip I didn't
want to think about distances I thought
about difficulties bottlenecks borders
the Sudan we have no embassy there a
very kind man named Tim Kearney I can do
was former ambassador to the Sudan help
me get a visa here's very good contacts
in the Sudan he was very very nice about
it and he has tremendous interest in are
becoming more acquainted with the Sudan
I would have put him in knowledge means
so I thought about the the travel is a
problem with solutions but you need
information to solve it it's not so much
the miles sometimes 20 miles can take
you know it's like war really it can
take a week 100 or 100 miles can take a
week and then you might find a bus or
train that's going for days and days
just get on and travel an enormous
distance as it is from same ones from
Lake Victoria to the coast there's a
that train that was
built once per by the british one by the
french you get on the train and they see
you say what is going to arrive and they
say maybe sunday maybe later but what
you know you're on the train you're
there and it's very beat up but you got
to make it eventually and so I try not
to think about miles who's the strangest
character you met on the trip this is a
very difficult question if when you
travel in Africa you meet all sorts of
people strange i would say i'd have i'd
say strange in the area of of how
wonderful was a sadiq el maadi who was
the former Prime Minister of the Sudan
someone said that they amend a
journalist in in cartoon when he said
I'd like to he said I just saw it sorry
Kalmadi he's a grandson of the Mahdi who
who who decapitated General Gordon and
he was himself decapitated by Kitchener
in annap unitive expedition the Battle
of Omdurman so this guy a wonderful
gentle intelligent handsome hog-nosed
romantic straight out of the Arabian
Nights fellow invited me to his twist
soiree really there was some writers
there and one of his wives and his
daughter and some friends we SAT there
drinking tea and and talking about
Africa and Sudan and politics in general
literature poetry music it was just
wonderful it was one of those the
evenings which could have taken place at
any time and let's say the 19th century
where the chief of a people the leader
of a people invites the foreigner
Richard sir richard burton or speak or
livingston the chief says come here's a
his TNA and they just talk about the
world the west and
what they know of it and they ask
questions Sadiq Almonte was a great
listener and one these days I suppose
he'll be back in power they have a
military issues a military government at
the moment Sudan you say is the largest
country in Africa is the largest country
in Africa and is embodies all of
Africa's greatness with all of Africa's
problems I mean there's been a war in
the south ever since I lived in Africa I
lived in Africa in the 60s and in the
60s they were fighting in the South in
Juba Malik hall and there was liberation
Army's and so forth the south is
christian and and forested in jungles
and swamps the Sud that were it's the
you know the the upper nile provinces
and then the end of north and central
are Islamize and I wouldn't say our byes
really although they are somewhat but
different people there are Nubians and
so forth and so it has war it has peace
it has oil it has poverty it has hungry
people that has wealthy people it you
know it's got all of it it's a wonderful
place what day would you say or period
was your most exhilarating period in the
five and a half months and which day
would be the low point where you thought
maybe you may not even make it there's
always a low many low points there were
days I can think of northern Kenya going
through the desert in northern Kenya you
wouldn't have thought so you would have
thought up upper egypt or Sudan that
would be tough going and yet it's not a
piece of cake but I made it made it
through but there were days I remember a
day when i was on a cattle truck and the
road was so bumpy the cattle had fallen
down they were on this side of the men
were twisting their tails to get them up
right then think the car got a flat tire
they pulled off the tie it was an inner
tire and that the car was propped up on
a very rudimentary Jack that was sinking
in the sand there was no shade for I
mean I could see 20 30 40 miles I guess
I could see 50 miles there wasn't a one
patch not even a poster
stamp of shade that I could see the road
wasn't a road the landscape wasn't a
landscape it was just rocks and gravel
looked like an immensity of kitty litter
everywhere as far as you could see and
so we're sitting by the side of the road
and I said to the man to drive a Mustafa
you know Fania Nene what's happening
here he said this blankety-blank road I
said well do you have it you gotta pump
you gotta got another time now and I
thought you know it was two o'clock in
the afternoon very hot what now what now
and then the band that they were they
were kicking the tire to pull the tire
off I'm making a meal of this I realized
but i was thinking i need a miracle here
and then you get a miracle if you wait
long enough miracles happen about an
hour later I was pretty hot actually
another truck came down the road I said
to the guy I waved him and I said can I
get in he said you can get in if you
ride on top so I climbed up to the top
of the truck sort of thing dad I aren't
you a little bit too old for this my
children saying climbed up and off we
went I thought this is great but then
about 20 miles around down the road we
got shot at there were bandits and but
the driver flawed it on we went and
eventually I made it to a town called
masab it which is not the end of line
that's in the middle of the desert and
had a night's sleep there so wasn't so
bad when you say the top of the truck
what do you really mean holding on to
the the the rails on top of the cab so
you're standing on a pipe overlook
overlooking the cab of the truck looking
forward and there's a man beside me it
turned out that Batman had a gun I think
he might have been a soldier or an
escort of some kind so I'm standing he's
there with his gun and other kids
holding on and then below me in the on
the flat bed of the truck or the rails
right were 20 head of cattle so it's um
yes the wind in your hair you know all
the all the wonderful all the features
all the comforts wasn't bad to tell you
through it's the only way to go by Road
there is no other way if you don't do
that you don't go by Road I suppose you
could rent a car well no you can't rent
a car but you could import your own SUV
I don't know there are charity charities
that go up and down that road from time
to time but they didn't pick me up ask
them for rides they said no you know
we're not running a taxi service as a
matter of fact well we're on that I just
have I haven't opened to a page that
you're in Malawi at this point and you
say I was not surprised when they
refused to give me a lift I knew from
experience that they were the last
people to offer travelers assistance
still I was annoyed I analyzed my
annoyance it was that the vehicles were
often driven by Africans the white
people riding his passengers and what
resembled ministerial seats they had CD
players usually with music playing
loudly and now and then I saw the whole
deal an African or a white person
driving in his white saved the children
vehicle one-handed talking on a cell
phone with music playing the happiest
person in the country for every agent of
virtue i saw slugging his or her guts
out in the field i saw two of them
joyriding but many times over do it
you'd you don't like these charity
people I don't dislike them but I
question the motives and and I think in
many cases they're like everybody else
that they their self dramatizing rather
priggish on their own honour on their
own version of Africa doing whatever
they're doing you find I mean there are
some us saintly some some aid workers
are very hard working to see the aid
worker though as a figure of salvation
is something I unpersuasive it's a very
unpersuasive figure I think aid is a
business these people aren't salaries
they they're looking in the most literal
sense they're looking for trouble when
there is trouble a serious famine a
serious Massacre they can raise money I
don't say if they welcome such things
but it gets it's easier to
raise money if there's if this serious
trouble it's just humdrum you no
ordinary aid I think they're less
interested III can't run them down
because they're doing something but 40
years ago such people were pretty thick
on the ground in Malawi and Zambia and
Tanzania Uganda and Kenya countries that
I know pretty well they're still there
they're the NGOs are like a parallel
structure parallel government when is an
NGO non-governmental organization key
name one giving example say the children
would that be one I suppose save the
children is one Oxfam is one they have
lot the Hunger Project of evil mission
against ignorance and poverty the food
project actionaid you to have a bunch of
mustard here sure and a World Vision
whatever and they're running things they
got a pumping pumping water there but
supposing is dispensing food they got a
clinic they tend not to have schools
they tend not to be involved in
education although some of some are and
some of them are faith-based initiatives
so you might say well god bless them but
they're there many of them with a Bible
in one hand and food in the other and
saying if you if you want this you've
got to have that meanwhile we have
pinstriped morons pretending to run a
government driving around and
mercedes-benz benz's politicians who are
getting on with the thing and going to
big important meetings well the
charities are running the essential
services in the country that would be
okay if they were run well but they're
not run well I think it's sort of it
prevents people from seeing the true
failure that of the government's and you
might say I mean the worst thing you can
say about them is why they still there
or let's say the plainness questions no
problem has been solved some lives have
been saved that's a good thing you can't
say that they shouldn't they do [ __ ]
they show
be distributing emergency aid but you
understand that they're doing the
government's work and they're doing it I
suppose for their own purposes Africans
should be doing things for themselves
they should be co-opted they should be
helping they should be volunteering they
should be sharing the burden sharing the
sacrifice but they're not they're paid
tax for most of these agencies most of
these charities how often are they
Americans the agency's the charities
they aid people you see there when you
know people buzz by and there's SUVs and
you plenty of Americans plenty of
America and they did they have any idea
who you were no no I i I'm I'm just guy
I'm just a bill age guy in a dusty
t-shirt saying hi you know although I
did say to uh I said the one they said
we're not gonna pick you up well no no I
can't give you a ride i said i was stuck
I said well I'm going down the same road
as you are if I and I'm in a truck
that's being fixed if I see you by the
side of the road I'm gonna go straight
by him and if you're in a ditch you're
going to stay in the ditch I said I
spoke were supposed I thought was
supposed to help each other if you're
not gonna help me then I'm gonna drive
by almost to tell the driver to drive by
this was in a desert also in Kenya with
the Americans yeah yeah medical people
god bless him but they're not there to
help they would say well he's a
backpacker he's a hitchhiker who's he
he's a bum but I'm there you know this
is the best thing the Calif Haroun
al-rashid used to go around Baghdad in
the disguise to find out what life was
really like in Baghdad and I feel that's
what I do I don't want to go as a member
of the American Academy of Arts and
Letters author of a number of books and
family favorites uh I don't think that
I'm a household name but I wasn't
advertising myself I would read that's a
story I came back I don't want people
offering me patronage and help and then
and then refusing it to other people I'd
like to think okay this is this is the
story that's how you find the story I
think how are you treated as a white man
you know this is a really interesting
question because 40 years ago when I
traveled in Africa if I got on a bus or
try
if I was standing by the side of the
road people would wander up and say you
know hello mr. hello jumbo habari Gani
moaning will you bungee and will you
come from you American yeah Elvis I like
Elvis they liked country music to
country western music and they would
they would ask searching questions in
some case all just about you know
whatever it was Cowboys have you ever
seen a cowboy 40 years later I'm in
Africa I get on a bus people move over
to give you a seat hello nan hello the
fact that I'm white or a foreigner
doesn't get anyone's pulse racing I am I
was very interested I could sit on a bus
and be completely ignored as a foreigner
as Amazon goo a white man a Ferengi as
they say and so that that's a major
difference they've seen plenty of my
kind and and dressed you know the way it
was I don't look like I'm you know
official I don't look like I have any
money excuse me and so a white person is
often or foreigner less conspicuous
they've seen so many aid people even
when you offer as I did I call the
Embassy in Malawi and I said would you
like to give a lecture well we're pretty
busy you know play they get plenty of
people want to give a lecture you want
to give some money you want to help out
you know take a number we'll call you we
get lots of people who want to do things
like that and I in my time people are
very grateful oh you're going to give a
lecture or you offering something or
you're even you're from the other world
the big world the first world come have
a seat but there's less interest now
people a bit jaded by it they've seen me
they've seen my type so many times you
for them are not interested and also
officially a lot of embassies a lot of
agencies you walk in and say I want to
volunteer well they got plenty of
volunteers foreigners we're not exotic
anymore and it's not news and there's
plenty of aid back to a question i asked
you earlier
talking about the low point what about
the most exhilarating time I think the
most exhilarating thing that can happen
to you in travel and happened to me many
times in Africa is to make some kind of
discovery about myself about the place I
mean someone tells you something i
always think it has a human dimension so
in kenya i met a man I knew him by name
he's a journalist and we were talking
just in general and then he confided the
fact that he had been in prison not that
long ago and started talking about his
time in prison so I said you know I'd
like to hear about it and we sat down
you said this doesn't sound like
exhilarating stuff but for purse to
spend a whole day listening to someone's
story of how he was arrested how he was
tortured how he suffered how he wrote
about it after his release what he's
doing now which is still writing that's
a whole it it's a biography of a man in
the country and he becomes like a
representative of the country for me and
it used you begin to understand much
better what what the country is when you
see how they persecute a man like that
that was in Kenya is that more common
he's called a book mahomie muta he
mahomie and muhammad ahi and other kinds
of exhilaration on I tell you it's just
the riding in a truck looking at looking
at the land going by seeing Adam at
sunset on a train looking out and seeing
as the Sun sets you know that when gold
is very very hot it's turns pink so this
pinkish gold yellow sunset and then you
see an animal an elephant I saw looking
out at the train pink golden elephant
just drinking at a pool of the wind if
it rains sort of the classic image of
africa but i'm on a train writing my
notes and thinking this is heaven
because i'm on the train there's
africans on the train i'm talking them
look out the window and you know we off
we go
to the night wonderful wonderful the
other ex-prisoners this fella I don't
have pronounce it mekonnen yes nippy
mikkonen the reason in Ethiopia yeah the
reason I bring it up is I want to ask
you about the fact that he had
translated gone with the wind not just
translated gone with the wind in prison
but he was in prison for two years with
nothing he's a very intelligent man its
misery we know the misery of being
without a book with being it without the
printed word to just be alone you can be
alone with your thoughts but for two
years if you're a literary person you
just crave the sight of print and a man
came into the prison where they hadn't
served searched him thoroughly he had a
copy of Gone with the Wind and the end
this is a barracks are you know prison
block with 150 people guys and they had
nothing to read so they passed this book
around each person had it for an hour or
half an hour I think and he had it he's
had the idea of translating it and then
reading it at night to the other
prisoners so that's what he did but of
course he had no paper so they used the
foil the back of the foil and a
cigarette pack is paper so they just
moved out subtle square and and he wrote
and translated the entire text of Gone
with the Wind and then when he got and
they smuggle him out of the prison and
he said they just they folded them any
as a man went out he would have a couple
in his shirt pocket no one checked them
they're flat and then for two years
after he got a use in prison for seven
years nebu mekonnen and when he got out
he rounded up this I think he said it
was 3,000 pieces of paper and put them
together typed it up and there's there's
the translation of Gone with the Wind
but that was his entire his entire
prison term was Margaret Mitchell pretty
good story in Ethiopia I was told if you
meet five minutes in a room four of them
will have been in prison at one time or
another you have talked a lot about your
weave in and out little tidbits about
your own personal life including the
fact that Graham Greene was one of your
favorites and
there were others and Ernest Hemingway
was not one of your favorites Ernest
Hemingway would is a I think clearly a
myth Oh maniac of the type that I've
described before he went to Africa had
no interest in African none of the
politics none in the society none no
even ethnographic interest and he was
among people who you know this is it he
was there in the 20s the 30s the 40s 50s
but he was only interested in shooting
animals so I for him to be in a place
where in many cases the people were
while not exactly untouched their
culture was still intact he could have
found out so much he could have if he
had been curious about africans he could
have said so much but it's part of his
narcissism and he was a he's a very
strange man this does the psychology of
there's something epicene there's
something homoerotic about Hemingway and
his work not to his disparagement but
that's never he's always seen as kind of
macho figure but I don't believe he was
I think he had no interest in women no
interest in African the Africans that he
was among he was merely a safari type
are very familiar kind who had enough
money to hire a gun Bearer and to go and
kill animals some of his story is set in
Africa quite good the short happy life
of Francis Macomber and the snows of
kilimanjaro obviously very good but
they're not about Africa though they're
about tourists you learn the year at
least two cents is it Marcel and Louis
yes Louie Louie Louie has his own TV
show in any in England on bbc2 it's
called weird weekends he does a lot of
traveling and interviews he's been to
South Africa he interviewed Eugene
Terblanche a white supremacist who's now
in jail for murder so Louie travels a
lot Marcel also Marcel's expertise is in
the Russian language and in Siberia he's
been to the northern part of cyber
Siberia the the event people where they
have a shamanistic culture and he's done
a number of documentaries there
and has written two novels how many
chillin you haven't all again I have
four altogether and one in Hawaii
another in Boston so it's a big two
marriages well those are the with three
women we would say three mothers two
marriages yeah and I also see medford
massachusetts in Cape Cod and Hawaii
what role did Medford play in your life
Medford was a Medford well you know
there's a book by um Oh about James
Thurber where it's called the clocks of
Columbus and there do you know the
expression the clocks of Columbus
therapist said whenever I hear a clock
chimes in my dreams it's a clock of
Columbus Columbus Ohio and Medford you
know medford made me i was a boy scout
in medford one of my fellow Eagle Scouts
was Mike Bloomberg was the mayor of you
know we both went to medford high school
he was a year behind me Mikey he was
good kid actually in a very good Scout
in the most literal sense he was an
Eagle Scout so as I so being an Eagle
Scout medford is a place where i went to
public schools they were we there were
multiracial schools so are we in the
1950s i had many black schoolmates as
well as many of you know white Jewish
that they went in all directions we even
had a future mafia hitman in our class
and so Medford being a very mixed
community just outside of Boston one end
of it very urban the other very rural
was a wonderful place to grow up and so
I could go we had access to the woods so
I shot my first gun they're built a fire
went used to go on camping trips in the
Medford fells Middlesex fells it's
called and I still go i mean you can
still go in the winter you can go
cross-country skiing they have bridle
paths and so forth it's still a good
place and and we were it was a very
short ride into boston so we had the
bent its it was just wonderful being
able to
have this the historical tradition of
Boston which we all knew you know Paul
Revere had come through medford and
Fannie Farmer and was was a Medford
figure and metal icicles we had a good
school system so very happy at Medford
made me I think where did you get
interested in writing I began writing I
suppose my parents are reading to me
filled me you you can't read a lot
without being the least bit curious
about wanting to be a writer you read
stories you think well I have stories I
you read stories about secrets and you
think I have secrets I could I could
tell those secrets I have things have
happened to me you fantasize when you're
young didn't you think it never happened
to anybody else my my you know the in
the recesses of my mind have these
strange and wonderful tales and so
reading my father used to read us
treasure island then we would be dr.
Seuss books for that matter when we
weren't much younger and I thought from
a very early age I I wanted to be I
wanted to write but I grew up in a
period the 50s was such a period it's
news to a lot of people not to you but
writers were magical people but writers
were inaccessible they didn't appear on
television very often the television
programs at the time were entertainment
shows you would not see John O'Hara or
James Jones or James Michener Sloan
Wilson those were the sort of popular
writers at the time you'd never see JD
Salinger on on on a show but and yet if
you wouldn't see him now either for that
matter but the writer was a very
powerful figure in the only equivalent
it now would be a pop star they had
their reputations and an aura of a
mystique around them that is is hard for
someone now to grasp but it was true and
so wanting to be a writer was also
wanting to be initiated into
a community of people who were who have
still very very ambiguous I mean we
didn't know all the details we just know
there were remote and wonderful people
so if I said I wanted to be a writer if
I didn't I wasn't quite sure of what I
was saying so I used to think I want to
be printing off I want to be a writer
but i'd like to get what i have printed
and then see what happens after that
it's very difficult to say you want to
be a writer anyway nowadays may I
suppose people do say I want to be a
writer at that time it was a forbidden
wish and I wanted to be a doctor too i
mean it and so it was easy for me to say
i want to be a doctor much harder to be
a writer you mentioned in the book your
brother Peter where does he live and he
was mentioned for translating a book I
believe peter is in Washington right
here and he he's with the State
Department he's an analyst he's an Arab
scholar and travels the the Middle East
in there's a printer problems
problem-solving capacity he's a
wonderful very smart guy I have four
brothers I have another brother in
Washington Eugene who's a lawyer with a
large law firm here I have a brother in
hello who's a school principal and so as
an Alex who's a novelist and I have two
sisters anne-marie and Mary there one's
a nurse one's a teacher it's a bit I've
come from a family of seven children
where did you go to college I was at the
University of Massachusetts in Amherst
and I should say also that coming from a
large family it's it's easier to think
of yourself to fantasize about becoming
a writer if you come from a large family
because you you are inevitably trying to
find a space you know a big family
there's not a lot of space you so you're
trying to you think well what am I going
to do and so you're looking for a role
to play it's not like someone's not
breathing down your neck saying what are
you going to do what are you going to do
you kind of have to work it out for
yourself because there are too many
people around and you're looking for
your place in the world and I think to a
large extent you want to leave you want
to leave the big family and have a place
of your own you said you do read
heart of darkness Joseph Connor has
booked 12 times at least I had a copy
with me the whole time through Africa it
was the book I had two books with me I
caught the heart of darkness and montane
three essays by Montaigne on thumbs on
the cannibals and on reading and on
cannibals is is about how other people
can seem very barbarous but be very
civilized and there's lots of wisdom in
it conrad wrote two interesting short
pieces about Africa the outpost the
progress an outpost of progress and
heart of darkness heart of darkness is
like a prose poem and so you have to
read it and read it it's very enigmatic
and it's full of ambiguities but at the
bottom of it is a story of a high-minded
man who becomes accountable in in the
book Africans refer to as cannibals
they're there ISNA cannibal in Africa I
mean cannibals you need to find
cannibals you need to go to the Pacific
you go to a place like vanuatu used to
be New Hebrides or Fiji then you find a
tradition of cannibalism not practice
today I dare say now they eat spam or
corned beef I suppose they nearly
approximate the taste of human flesh I
don't know but Conrad is constantly
talking about Marlo is getting is
referring to or people are alluding to
cannibals but Kurtz has indulged in
cannibalism I think you get there after
12 or 13 readings I saw that where would
you say you wrote most of this book
that's a good question i right when I
travel so i have a small notebook I
don't have a tape recorder I take notes
all day in a small notebook this
notebook a notebook just like this this
is unobtrusive I have it on my lap or
I'm talking to a person like yourself
and afterwards I make I would make some
notes in the evening I I have a larger
no much larger one and I it's a it's a
student notebook
and so I I a copy might be 1,500 2,000
words in the notebook and then at the
end of it I have six or seven large
notebooks which I bring back so where
did I write the book on route and then
afterwards and where do you write when
you afterwards is there a place is it
Cape Cod or is it Hawaii where you find
a better atmosphere I wrote this book I
was very ill at the end of the trip I
got seriously ill at it some sort of
stomach parasite the doctor said they
were parasites he said let's try this
let's treat this empirically and I must
say I went through quite a lot of
Sherman wrong trying to get rid of it I
then I had some sort of inflammation
they said then a kind of intolerance fat
intolerance malabsorption syndrome this
is serious stuff but the worst of it is
you can't write about it I you can't
write about ailments in a book then on
intro really exotic ailment maybe but
this sort of thing is not not
interesting to people getting robbed
being delayed and being sick and not
subjects for a travel fee you mentioned
them but the people reading the book
have had the same experience why did you
travel just down the east coast of
Africa and how many countries total did
you visit I every country from Egypt to
South Africa which is Egypt Sudan
Ethiopia Kenya Uganda Tanzania Zambia
Malawi Zimbabwe Mozambique then South
Africa and Swaziland when I go to the
end of the trip I thought I I was so
invigorated in south africa i could
easily have taken off and gone north
through south africa namibia angola the
congo brazzaville then Chad and then
through nazare but I had to come back it
would have been another six months and I
would have been away a year and I
thought maybe I'll do that sometime
it's simpler to go through north to
south or south to north on the
right-hand side of Africa West Africa is
much more difficult there are more Wars
Angola has difficulties but in general I
was thinking if you choose your route
and if you're not in a hurry you can go
anywhere who's standing in the middle of
this picture on the cover I have no idea
that some people in the some people in
the desert I didn't take this picture
and even said to them it looks like a
mariachi band but it's some women with
some things on their head that looked
like sombreros where did you get the
name for the book Dark Star safari that
was an image that kept occurring to me
when I was traveling i was thinking I'm
somewhere out of this world to coin up
use a user expression of Charles
Baudelaire anywhere out of this world
and it seemed to me that a dark star
embodied all the ambiguity of glitter
beauty light and yet still with a lot of
shadow in it because there are so many
wonderful things in Africa that I saw
that I experienced that I know exist and
so many difficulties so many problems
and so I was thinking this end it's a
place that is ignored there aren't a lot
of journalists foreign journalists in
Africa there are some they report on it
but in on the whole people go to Africa
only to look for catastrophes people go
the first line of my book is all news
out of Africa is bad it made me want to
go there not for the horror not for the
massacres but to see the other part to
connect the dots and to to cross borders
not to fly from one capital to another
or from one catastrophe to another what
is your wife do during the time your way
she does like Penelope are like Ulysses
Penelope she knits she has work and she
waits for the phone to ring and
sometimes it rings not often because in
Africa I because I didn't have a phone I
didn't have a computer but I
try to reassure her when I could it's
worse for the wives of sailors and
soldiers much worse they're in much
greater danger and they have a lot of
pain and sorrow and for them it's it's a
whole marriage of anyway a whole
lifetime of waiting for the husband or
the wife to come home how many people do
you think there are in the world and I
know this you can't know but there
aren't I guess better ways in there are
not many people that have been to as
many places as you've been and stayed
for that long time I guess I've
deliberately tried to do it i don't know
they know they must be there must be in
when you travel you see there are a lot
of humble anonymous people out there
just traveling they're just moving and
they for them it's it's a lifetime very
nomadic people Americans Europeans you
meet you know Germans on a bike you know
you meet a German guy and he he's got a
bicycle to see where and he says that
well you know traveling the world I just
took the you know I've got a pension or
whatever it is and or I got some money
and I'm just going and they're so I
can't take credit for uh uh for being
such a you know flying dutchman but I've
the difficulty I suppose has been
writing about it in my early part of my
life i thought i'm only going to find
out about the world by living in it so I
was in Africa for six years I was in
Southeast Asia in Singapore for three
years I lived in England for 17 years
and uh you know try that so when people
say gosh you know England must be hard
and I said well I lived in Uganda they
say what's the worst place to prevent
try you know the outskirts of Manchester
on a wet Sunday afternoon that makes you
know bundu bougie oh look like paradise
so what abou geo is on the Congo border
writing about it I had a mission of just
seeing as much of the world as I could
and I think of myself as a novelist and
the process of writing novels is can
only be done uncertainly indoors and
this has an indoor occupation it gives
someone like me
tremendous sense of confinement of
enforced solitude so after I finished
writing a novel I feel like getting out
but my I'm programmed to think that it
if I travel I have to turn it into
something sing for my supper make it pay
I had to pay for this trip myself
actually I couldn't get any magazine to
send me to Africa none was interested
other things were happening in the world
Africa is not in everyone's mind but I
thought it's a wonderful place it's a
strange place it's a worthy place and
although there are a lot of thieves
stealing the donor money in Africa the
donor money is not it's not large and
and it's a place that keeps changing
it's the source of humanity this is
today the day we record is your 62nd
birthday and in this book we get a lot
of references to growing older and the
fact that you were turning 60 in the
middle of this book what's it what's age
mean to you age is I suppose something
when you're young when you're 20 Oh in
your late teens 25 can seem old when
you're 20 30 seems old when you're 30 40
seems pretty old and fifty seems like
vario it so it's this shifting
perspective of 60 is the new 40 I've
told okay I'll buy that what age means
to me is that it's a fraud that that age
means nothing that's what it means
nothing that it's inside you and it's
your vitality your intelligence your
sense of creativity your imagination
those are the things that count so it's
it's offensive to be considered old if
people are only looking at your face of
course you think I still got it I can
cut the mustard I can ride on a truck
I'm not trying to prove anything but
don't think by looking at me that you're
looking at some of it that that has seen
the world you know and don't think I
can't do it again so you also
people young people can say a lot of
stupid things and they believe
particularly in Africa they believe that
history started last year or you know
they say things like you know in a
couple of years this could happen and
you do sound like a foggy when you say
look for 40 years people have been
saying that and it hasn't happened it
probably is going to happen in two years
you know I don't want to destroy your
illusions but it probably isn't going to
happen why don't we try it this way and
people used to say that to me when I was
young and impetuous and now I see what
they were driving at what's next I'm
working on a novel at the moment and
correcting the proofs of a book that I
started when I was traveling in Africa I
wrote a to keep busy I wrote a novel ax
I thought I'd be in Africa I didn't go
out at night it's not a good idea you
have to think of yourself as prey and
other people as predators it's no it did
not to demean them in any way but not a
good idea to go outside when it's dark
get up early that's the thing at night I
worked on a story and story grew and
grew and I in a way I missed my wife and
I so many women fluttering around
inevitably the story became erratically
charged so it's an erotic novella which
will be published in a few months in
England and early in as in january 2004
here it's called a the stranger at the
palazzo door oh we got to a tiny bit of
this 472 page book it's called Dark Star
Safari a lot more in here about our
guests time as a Peace Corps volunteer
and a teacher in Africa Paul through our
guests again the book darkstar Safari
thank you very much thank you very much
probably